all right hello everybody 11:00 a.m. we
are here on time
are we not normally on time I've been
struggling a little bit but you know
what today's the day it's Wednesday
happy Wednesday I'm Persia I'm here with
Jordan and I'm so excited to dragged
right and unto the Steven make him play
some video games with us cuz he's
awesome
I mean you've been on the game spotlight
before i right yeah I seen you before
I'm just new so it's a new experience
for me we can all enjoy this together so
today we're playing the Alpha demo of me
ot
[Music]
so if you played the purse neo then
you'll probably know a bit about like
this game in general
I was like oh my god that's so loud I
was like we're trying to spit some
knowledge right now he's just growling
in our face but yeah so this is like
some way to other Souls games yeah sorry
guys it was super loud
but yeah so we're gonna check out this
demo I am giving Jordan all the controls
today although I have played the first
one and I roamed around briefly in the
demo and it feels very similar to the
first one yeah give the dude has been
playing Sakura a completely different
type of swords like Xbox one the ps4
exclusive it's mine
Souls supposed to be like the hardest
game ever so this should be a cakewalk
you'll be a-ok I believe in you I guess
we could do a new game just kind of show
people a little bit as a tutorial stage
if you haven't played the first meal
it's super similar to the first Neos
little training stage and everything so
but we'll show you guys in case you
haven't actually played the first one
but in the meantime welcome everybody
box Knight is back
Jason's back oh this wouldn't this
popped up when I first started the demo
I was like I'm never gonna get this demo
started because I'm gonna be spending
like an hour customizing my character
but it's all blocked out you can only
really pick like male or female in like
a couple of base starting
characterisations but you can tell like
once the game actually comes out then it
can make your own character I don't
remember that being in the first one
yeah you have to play as just a regular
old but I think it's cool and like more
and more games are giving people the
option of like female character so you
know let me have my moment mm-hmm I'm
pretty happy about that but yeah you can
be a girl yo and then when you turn into
like your demon form you're like still
like a crazy demon but a little bit more
feminine demon a feminine demon
but yeah so this is training stage super
similar to the first neo super similar
I'm pretty sure everything it might like
the graphics are maybe a little bit
better
but yeah I hope everyone has been having
a good Wednesday a happy hump day just
send me a code I don't think that there
are any codes I know this is a closed
alpha I think like sometime in the past
you could have really signed up for a
possibly not 100% sure but I know it's
closed it's a closed alpha demo mm-hmm
its pretty long demo though because I
saw Alessandra play like a little bit of
it I think it took him like three hours
to finish the entire thing I mean the
first you know was like 45 hours or
something so three hours is then
actually all that big in comparison it's
like if they're giving you one person of
the game via demo imagine how long the
actual games gonna be I know the first
game was really long is this on pc we're
actually playing on ps4 the demos on ps4
um I guess I can look it up and see if
it's coming out on other platforms I
know the first neo I played was also on
PlayStation [ __ ] lead Ilya says this
game looks so damn clean it does it
looks really nice even like the menu
screen I was like yeah I took a picture
of it so pretty I love that we're
getting all of these like old Japanese
samurai type games like we got Sakura or
getting neo to or getting ghost of
Tsushima Samurai Shodown next month and
like in June so I guess the new thing is
the like demon transformation yeah so
that's like the exciting edition I mean
we saw - look I don't actually
we pulled up the title like cutscene in
time but you kind of see him in that
stance and later on in the training mode
you'll see them power up
yeah mr. sensible says this looks
exactly like the neo one yeah that's
what I was like when I played through it
I was like wait I think I've played this
game before and I'm like but that's
impossible right this this is a closed
demo game's not out yet and I was like
oh yeah I did play this the first me oh
I got it for free at a fighting game
tournament because Team Ninja was there
they were doing a DOA tournament and
then they were also giving away some
free games and so I got neo one for free
and you know I play a great game to get
cuz at first you know I didn't know
anything about it and usually when
people give away free games they're like
mediocre games but I was like man this
is an awesome free game as I was playing
it and it was it was pretty long so
oh yeah and I don't know if anybody has
seen it but go watch that death
stranding trailer the nine was amazing
honestly I didn't realize it was so long
I started it and had my headphones on
like full blast and I was watching it
and I was amazed and then it ended like
nine minutes later and I took my
headphones off I looked over and
everyone was in a meeting and I was like
oh and I just like sneaked over there
and then like two seconds later they're
like sorry but the trailer was too
beautiful man it was great it's the
first trailer I've seen where I'm like I
have an inkling of what might be
happening I'm still very confused but I
think I know what's going on
story-wise there's a lot of elements and
I need more context so I'm super excited
I love that they're like including all
these actors and so it's like movie
style and even at the end of the trailer
it looked like you know like a movie
trailer at the end where they have all
the the stars and stuff like that oh
yeah these are the presets for the
characters that you can use right now in
the demo I was using the second one of
course because I was like which is
usually how I pick most kids
she is the cute one we'll go with this
one someone said let me scroll of
because I saw scold yeah waiting for
schoolgirls to come to to come on the
switch yes Brandon I am too I am excited
I mean I still need to get my own switch
but I've been you know kind of leeching
off the one in the office and I've been
playing on a Tetris 99 and stuff but
once gold girls comes to switch I think
I really need to commit and buy and get
a switch no there's too many good games
now because there's like fighting
mhm and then you know got touches 99 of
course which is amazing there's a bunch
of like hidden indie gems on there too
like golf story and battle chef brigade
you've got to get a switch
yeah and crystal crisis just came out
yesterday I think for the switch also
which we played yesterday on the train
sword and shield is coming out on switch
there's a lot of good games coming to
switch pretty good
alright so tutorial mode successfully
successfully beaten I've done the
tutorial superior gameplay enjoyed and
we're talking about how you know you
play on different consoles and then you
go to a different console you start
pressing the wrong buttons it happens
all the time I think right now I'm the
worst on the switch with it when I play
a new game and it's like press this
button to do this action I had nine
times out of ten hit the wrong button
first and then I'm like oh yeah I'm
gonna it annoys me to no end Xbox ps4
and switch decide to just put their X
button in completely different places
like you guys did that on purpose they
were like why I want to be like but yeah
we are in the actual demo part now in do
one these little guys is little green
guys this is how I remembered that I
played the first Neil a lot because
those little green guys are so cute yeah
and you know when you're like getting
sliced up and your life is running low
and you see those little guys and you're
like yes salvation baby yeah getting the
goods now gotta keep your character
strong you know when I was younger and I
played like RPGs and stuff I didn't even
like know about things like that and
then you start getting a little bit
older and you're like oh there's this
and there's this and I got to put this
on I don't know why I remember that so
which out of like playing different
games growing up like I guess my
instinct as like oh nice block my
instinct as a kid wasn't very good I had
to learn okay I'll admit it hmm a couple
people in the chat talking about last of
us too
and someone says can we get a new
Bioshock I mean it's not a new Bioshock
but void bastard bastard yes it came out
today and it's made by Bioshock folks
and Michael Hardy has been talking up
and down about it for weeks on the
stream tomorrow so if you guys wanna
check that out come back tomorrow
box name says fighting games and Tetris
Persia I know right like what else do I
need in a console why haven't I gotten a
switch yet guys I'm slacking I'm sorry
you know we got bills to pay we got
bills to pay
[Laughter]
yes these new hatchets
okay okay okay hmm
chat say neo2 is supposed to be one of
the last ps4 exclusive games what sure
maybe let me scroll up maybe I missed
something before this like I don't think
Sony's gonna stop making PlayStation
exclusives yeah I really love that
trailer I saw that there were it was
that the only trailer because I saw the
long version and then like YouTube Auto
playlist was like oh one of four or like
who I have to come back to this just in
case its legendary I want to check it
out chat sometimes I don't know if I can
trust you because get me all excited and
sometimes it's like is there like
there's gonna be a Resident Evil a
trailer on June 6 where is your source
I'm also notoriously bad at like you
know being like one of the first people
to know something right I usually find
out all the good stuff when someone's
like did you see her did you hear which
is exactly what happened this morning I
came in he's like it's going fantastic
actually
I checked it out but how many gaming
tournaments was I in ask spot box night
well yes game spot technically geez
tournaments I've been in so many
tournaments I know I
it's hard to like actually put a number
to it because I mean I started going to
tournaments back in Halo 2 I got super
addicted to competing go to my locals
and you know they weren't anything
really crazy they were just like you
know game crazy at Hollywood videos or
like you know a little game section of
all the video stores little land centers
that was like one of my favorite you're
safe now
[Music]
but yeah competing back then competed
halo 2 and halo 3 they're way better
than a video game tonight what you're
saying you know that I think that
there's like difference in categories
with like game skill right cuz someone
could be super good at multiplayer games
or like you know shooters but then they
could play like a platformer and be ass
people are good at different genres and
then others do they prefer different
genres sometimes you will run it I know
I grew up with a few people who they
were always I got my head in yeah you
got the good trades we get shades yeah
some people are just naturally good at
like everything I knew someone like that
growing up just every game they touch
they were super good at it that's that
the raw gamer skill the blessed bestowed
upon them during birth or something you
know
but yeah obviously I'll be on xbox
sometimes and we'll see someone with
like several hundred thousand gamer
score and they've like presented all
these games I'm like how do you wear it
where's the time it's like oh no I just
beat it in like 30 hours I'm like how
are you so good people are really good
and then you know just years and years
of that a new game
coming out and sometimes I feel like
newer games are getting easier and
easier and then you get games like Dark
Souls that remind people hey remember
what it was like when games were really
hard remember who you were child and you
sucked at videogames soap says Persia
do you play League of Legends I do but I
only play a Rams I'm actually trying to
get a day on the stream to play some a
rams and and before you guys you know
get your pitchforks out are you know
they're shorter they're less competitive
but they're still fun and I mean
sometimes you get stuck with like a
champ that's not that great or like
toxic teammates but I mean that's more
of a League thing than it is like
gameplay thing but I think it's really
fun cuz I don't have the patience for a
normal not when I'm playing anyways like
I watch LCS and like tournaments and you
know competitive matches and I think
those are awesome because that's like
the highest level right see all these
characters in their full glory and all
these plays and stuff but that's a long
game for like one game I respect it I
just personally like a Rams cuz they're
quick and they're fun it's just one lane
I don't worry about getting ganked and
like it's fine wow it's like retry or do
you wanna do the tutorial like you suck
dude try the tutorial again we got this
we're back at the shrine we're good
oh is that an ally now better be I know
I know the red ones are evil but that
one was blue maybe they are like you
need some help there is a new teaser
from Capcom with a Resident Evil title
the day it says six 6:19 own ice okay
cool
when I was playing Halo last week with
Eric someone was like yeah
halo is totally on PC and Eric is like
oh really like I have to make sure
everyone you know you provide your
sources and then I can get excited
mr. sensible are you sure this isn't
Neil one honestly when I was playing
through the demo to you I was like this
stage is so similar but keep in mind
this is a demo a close demo alpha like
some still early even in the beginning
when you first start up the demo it's
like this does not reflect final
gameplay so just keep that in mind as we
check this out
it is strong
but yeah a Rams are awesome so you know
Aaron's like all random all mid so I
wanted to do all random all Monday I
love I love
well animation I like it look at all of
these evil spirits all these people they
have unfinished business in this world
Dino Crisis I need to stop trying to
Perry this is not Sakura you called that
to it you were like I'm gonna be trying
to bury this entire time it's just it's
so nice to just press the block button
and then flawless there's a lot about
are these all the bodies that you kill
there they're just more popping up I
don't know more people popping up oh oh
good there's lots of you I was reaching
down to get to the TV I'm like where is
it I'm like no oh right yes I saw
someone just post a picture of a ps4
controller that has the analogs and the
d-pad in the place of like an Xbox
controller so like left analogs up top
and deep pads online custom controllers
man that's the future
[Music]
he's impaled by rogue last time you were
cut down this time impaled I mean once
they start crowding around you like that
I totally forgot that in normal souls
games you're actually supposed to like
go back and try to get the things that
you lost I'm so used to sector oh where
it's like oh no it's just gone like you
died you can't get it back it's like a
peg go back for your box don't we gonna
try to use here I think the low stance
you get like a lot of quick attacks got
the hatchet though ooh
the dodge let's go oh yeah a 360 hitbox
on that spear nice break the guard slice
them up yeah hey if the blue guys are
friendly I would just revive like all
the blue guys and I'm just gonna take my
blue guy army and rush it down I think I
have enough resources yeah oh you need
stuff so of course the Evo guys are like
now these guys free just you can turn
around the classic like game stuff can't
see me if I'm 10 feet out of range even
though I'm right in your line of sight
oh good nice using the the key
it's like active reload slowly coming
back decapitated
it's gone
as with most heads once they leave the
body they just disappear and to be out
there what's up Bob Jones it's going
well thanks for asking I hope you're
having a great Wednesday and everyone
else in the chat we're having a great
Wednesday we're halfway through the week
already I mean it was kind of shortened
because of Memorial Day but it's all
good so doing the thing yes give me
those arrows yeah I like the action ha
ha oh I can't let this one go to waste
it was too good you could have let it go
it's perfect you don't need to shout at
me he lost a lot of blood in that last
slice I don't know how he's still
standing noise see it's all coming back
to you it's all coming back slowly but
sure I need help
oh I hope this game won't have swords in
it it definitely has swords we're just
using the axes right now I mean it has
to I think it's like defaults this game
will have swords like all of these
demons have a sword sticking out of
their bodies
so you think it's almost guarantee
however this is a demo so things could
change
oh you are feeling feisty
onu yeah he's only got one eye though oh
boy and one leg heal heal heal heal
he's like an angry pogo stick you got
this you got one more leg in one more
eye than he does I think it oh nice oh
my god the 360 hitbox it's okay we got
some oh my god that did so much damage
I'm fine
everything's fine Oh block those rah rah
I'm gonna need you to stop
[Laughter]
nice okay oh nice see you oh you're
still good
upon Vitara dattara dattara interesting
yeah they always have these crazy names
I can't pronounce and here we are again
and the little guy you saved he's
chillin too yeah this definitely feels
so much like Mia one like right back at
it it's like watching John wick one and
then watching John with - it's like
seamless like boom boom there we go
actually story wise I'm not I'm not sure
the story for this game yeah it takes
place I want to save 50 years it takes
place before the first game Oh
interesting that's really interesting if
you think about it so they no longer if
you if you put it in order right leg
five story like hey it's all good so
it's a sequel prequel we will take the
coward's way around he doesn't see it's
okay
oh snap
Jonathan subscribe to our channel thanks
man we appreciate that and thanks for
tuning in and if this is one of your
first times checking us out we are live
every day Monday through Friday at 11
a.m.
sometimes the times change a little bit
depending on what we play for example I
think on Friday they're playing a dim
or a beta but it's only open during
certain hours so they might have to move
the stream to later hours but if it's
not something like that then yeah we'll
be live at 11:00 or maybe like 1102
sometimes if it's just be honest
honesty is key hey we were on time today
dang you just shot you and your back the
disrespect not even looking at you out
snipe him get in our hanzo on God bows
and suck you out
oh boy dodged
I like how she dodged more like on this
roof she was fighting against the boss
like she was super yeah like where was
this where were these moves where for
these Jukes
all right yeah so reckless to an
objective I think it's up these stairs
we're gonna slice this real quick
don't be sitting on my porch oh here's
big boy in the back to just duck and
leave just duck and weave oh man they're
not gonna follow you in here are you no
one's deal with the boss in luciana they
gave up cowards
all right he's awake evil pogo stick how
do you download this demo this demo is a
closed alpha demo so unless um
you previously signed up for it or you
know subscribe to it or something I'm
not 100% sure how they handed out the
codes I just know it's closed so I don't
wanna give like false info someone's
like I definitely email
but if you played me a1 and you liked it
I would definitely recommend playing
this one because it's gonna feel like
riding a bike right back in oh yeah
proving that right here riding a bike in
different countries I go on the other
side of the road for you specifically
hopping over from Xbox yes that is a
strong bleed to block that the stream is
not enough to beat the boss yeah we
might need more time now we saw of an
hour I believe in you you can get you
can get this guy in an hour I love your
faith in me and our is plenty of time
you says he's stuck at the second
mission boss so I guess after this we
will we will see if we get stuck there
as well this dream is brought to you by
pain yeah the pain we're gonna inflict
oh you're a demon to come over here oh
why won't you die an additional minute
from from when I said we had an hour
come on guys
that was easy easy totally easy
oh yeah shut up the team ninja doing
good work
give me that good stuff yeah more axis
I like the axis i sever that half just
went in the first one right I can't seem
to remember using double axes especially
ones that you could throw um I don't
remember either I remember using a lot
of arrows because like always scared to
get too close to people and then swords
in a while since I played the first one
so so I also apologize on that into I'm
like if I wouldn't know we're gonna play
this today a my mind was out neo one for
a little while ever say if I known I was
gonna be pulled into this I probably
would have practiced it see I'm just
like having around the office like
alright make the sprays and play games
with me but it's fun it's just
everyone's so busy and I always feel so
bad like pulling people away from their
work I love that you asked me whether or
not I could play before telling me what
the game was it's like can you help on
this dream I'm like sure I
like and it's gonna be neon I did
realize after telling you that I'm like
I could have screwed myself on this
there's a possibility that this won't
end well for me I'm so chilled those
double axes are anneal nice
thanks for the confirmation I appreciate
that
Mike the knight hello to you as well
thanks for tuning in and thanks for
everyone else who's been sticking with
us so chilled also asked how easy of a
transition was it from playing Sakura to
neo to basically proof of concept
the only control that stays is that the
left bumper is blocked I can defend
myself
the controls are an adjustment 50/50
balance right I can't rest at this
bonfire someone asks is this the closed
alpha yes it is thanks for tuning in
subset Sakura is still the hardest
yeah that's why Jordan yes I would never
describe a song like shade samurai so
hey bro hey Jordan thanks for the stream
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
by it today inside out yet because that
I need I love all those guys for my desk
just like a real one though so you can
walk around and wave at me and I'll tell
him to pass me my coffee and he'll pick
it up and walk it over so this is what
goes on in my brain you look like you
might make my day I don't know he looks
like he doesn't want to deal with this
okay never mind change his mind oh oh
god he's a Koopa oh oh is he so mean
he's trying to summon that guy he's like
a little blue gremlin thing you've got
the breakdancing moves ding give me your
money give me your stuff yeah he was
hoarding under that shell
my cue says rest in peace pausing he
spanked his butt at me I was gonna let
that slide shade samurai says this is
day five of me playing Neo Geo and I
have greatly enjoyed the game that's how
long this demo is that is amazing I
admit I am enjoying my friends yeah I
love that every time you go back once
you save them there's all of them go
there so then later on you just have the
whole squad chillin like yeah I just
watched Despicable Me 2 so I think I'm
also writing on like the minion hype
yeah equip believe I can level up as
well let's get some more health Mike the
Knights are you ready for outer wilds so
I heard everyone the office talking
about it and then people are like oh do
you mean outer world oh yeah like and
like mixing it up with all these similar
titles but I actually haven't seen
anything of it I'm gonna say outer why
is the one that's coming out first and
that one is basically Groundhog Day
meets Majora's Mask in space
you're basically caught in like a time
loop where every I think 20 minutes in
real time it resets and sends you back
to the same point and you're trying to
like solve a mystery like traveling from
planet to planet and you know what's
going to happen so you're trying to fix
the mistakes that you make and each run
I played it at e3 last year and it was
it was pretty dope I'm excited for it
another Xbox console exclusive bring you
Xbox outer insert name here outer wilds
and know the outer worlds and outer wild
yeah and I think someone said outer
Haven
is that an hour heaven is that another
game so many games so many games just I
just write about what's in the news I
can't get over that is pretty cool what
is your favorite weapon set currently
well we kind of just started fiddling
with the demo pretty fun a little bit of
slicing and dicing I remember in the
original neo it took me a while to get
good with them but I really liked using
the chain blade like things even though
they were just being on yeah I like I
mean anything dual wield it was like has
instant appeal
a strange force you say but yeah no that
sounds really cool I also really like
space wow he's really creepy looking at
that size like they're almost kind of
cute when they're little but that size
not so much no his belly's glowing is he
gonna pop Oh God tried to hug me
stop trying to hug me just below me
child
oh nice do you get some invincibility
while you do that that's nice
some secret Tech right there for y'all
we just found it no let's not do that
again
Mike's and I asking about that stranding
trailer again we mentioned it earlier
but ya know bitten to death I I was
fully expecting
have you played suck here oh I like
played through the beginning at a
friend's house like they had just got in
you're like yeah we're check it out and
I play like a little bit beginning and I
was getting destroy it I was like oh my
god that reminded me of the headless and
sucker oh these enemies that are
headless they'll like sneak up behind
you and they reach up your butt and they
pull out your insides and then stuff it
up their own butt and then you die and
I'm like what did what did I just like
you sit back and think about it you're
like someone we need to develop that and
make that a reality what do you want me
to do Jim see what's going to happen it
oh man yeah that was something oh yeah
so this is obviously a demo so my
feedback so far would be make our heads
rip off when we get bitten to death like
that you know she fell back down her
head was still attached and I was like
oh no we already decapitated somebody so
we know that heads can roll I need to
get out I need to get out ooh dual
katanas that sounds cool he's got the
ultimate cold attack like hair styled
one on two wow he kicked you Jacky shot
down
what do you throw a rock at you whatever
it was it wasn't very strong I had like
a slither I fell oh you have to kill
them quickly because they eat each other
to get bigger
I see they just get more and more creepy
as
all right I need to kill all of you very
quickly that's what I've been told speed
speed
don't eat each other it's not nice no
[Laughter]
um will we be trying out Borderlands 3
when it is released heck yes I enjoyed
my time with it I think that the coolest
thing about working here is I've been
able to play games again you know for a
while there it's like I was kind of busy
with like travelling going to events so
I was focusing on you know a very small
handful of fighting ins so not only was
I weary about spending extra time on
games how I wanted to because I was
trying to like hone my craft for
commentary and stuff like that but games
are also expensive like at least here
it's like you know they're already here
and I'm like yay so now I could play it
and it's awesome
but you know like 60 bucks every time a
new game comes out and if we really
think about this year and video games in
general like we got so many
announcements and releases and new games
and you know new consoles on the way and
I'm just like this is all fantastic
don't get Mirana
I love it I just wish I was rich people
do like everyone in the office chips in
like 20 bucks and then we all go buy
lottery tickets and then if one wins we
split it up the whole office I've always
wanted to do that but I've never worked
in a place until now where I was
actually like oh yeah I would trust
these coworkers well thank you for
trusting us and say the thing that's
gonna throw you which I discovered last
year during the game of the year
conversation everyone's gonna start
bringing up all these games I'm like
wait but I haven't I haven't played all
of these and they're gonna have to try
to play like 30 games in like 20 days
but it's a good problem I mean I've been
really enjoying like I'm gonna grind out
certain games for certain streams and
learning more about it cuz games you
getting so advanced now they are like I
think back to like older games I've
played thinking like those were pretty
cool and now it's like oh yeah a lot to
do now days gone when I was playing that
I was like this game's never gonna end
this game so yeah after watching you all
play that game I decided I liked the
story I didn't get to finish it because
it was so long but the story was good it
like I was like I don't know maybe like
20 hours in and I cried like three times
I'm sorry guys he was like trying to
find his wife and he's also like you
know
toughened by this post-apocalyptic world
but of course he has this soft spot and
you know she's dead but there's all
these little things pointing to the fact
that she might be alive but then I never
really got at that point it was fun it
was fine it was fine I've gone in a
circle that's fine it's all good
we got Oh big boy he saw you now we're
good we're nimble he's slow reactions oh
oh yeah it's multiple times
[Music]
yoky bear
yes I'll dodge next time thank you for
that pro tips now our unpurified soul
cores wait you have to fight the little
of cannibals again yep no the large
yokai's biggest weakness dual axes and a
lot of circling well I got half of that
right hit him with high stance from
behind he will fall and then just stab
nice yeah that is something I like like
each stance probably works a little bit
better against different bosses which is
like another in depth element right
again I'm like touching back on when
like man when I was a young stupid gamer
clearly because of all the stuff but you
know I know now I'm like man would have
like eight-year-old me been like oh yeah
high stance low stance midstance and
once I was playing the game for like oh
no now we got everyone in on the action
I didn't I didn't want to bring you out
yet I get off my lawn I didn't want to
bring you out yet leave my kid why are
you here where did you come from
oh man well at least they didn't run
over there to eat the other bodies oops
he slipped and fell
that would be me as like a zombie bad
guy oh my goodness that was that was
rough
when you get us all car immediately go
back to the homies UPS shrink get back
into that dark souls 3 mindset so you
sit just like dying they're just gone
forever there's no point in like
sneaking past enemies because you're not
going to recover any of it
Dugan asks also can you make your own
character you can like oh you can't in
the demo right now but we did see like a
ton of customization options at the
beginning you like male or female they
have some base options to start with in
terms of books but they have everything
like eyes nose cheeks like I personally
love games with stuff like that
it takes me way too long to create my
character but I really really like it I
always started off trying to make it
look like me as much as possible and
then once it starts like failing I just
tried to make the character like oh yeah
most people in Japanese games don't have
my hairstyle
you didn't eat him I killed him I saw it
no piata snack
oh no no he missed me miss that's so
cheap that is so G Richard says he's
getting a diablo feeling hello Ben help
me this guy ate his friend see the head
should be gone the head should be gone
please please add that will we be doing
co-op with players today not today
but every Friday we have a community
Friday is in which Ben and John Luke
they hold it down and play games with
you guys and I think they can be playing
something really fun this Friday but it
might get it for some time so make sure
you tune in and plus I'm not sure we can
do go up can you do you've got this
droid and I believe in you and then Bob
Jones says tell him to dodge more of it
use your bow yeah do you saw some air
all right
long range that's that's a strategy that
exists in this game
oshi zamurai says yeah you could play
the demo co-op that's pretty awesome we
probably won't won't be doing that today
although that would be kind of cool
oh no you're done the arrows top-tier
thank you for amazing oh there's another
one oh boy
he's throwing rocks or is that poop you
might be throwing this poop at you which
is why it does so much damage know where
the arrows no no takes too long with the
arrows I think yeah hack and slash and
lots of circling this is what our chat
tells us and it looks like Oh circle
which way circle which way your belief
was misguided Ben no you know what we're
getting a little better every time so
you got this
I believe in you too last time we were
the last boss we're like you have an
hour and you beat it like amazing that's
what I need I need that challenge of
being like Jorgen sucks at this game
like I'll show you I'll show you all
because you know people need to remember
though like don't you ever remember the
time you like plead something for the
first time or went back to something
after a long time it's not gonna be like
easy-peasy the first go but then once
you warm up you good
I can't believe he dodged that Bailey's
um Adrian asks if I stream I stream here
one day I did used to stream on my own
personal channel daily but I've moved
here to San Francisco and I do not have
a stream set up at the moment but I'm
hoping to get all my equipment back
really soon it's just still in my old
place of residence yeah I do plan on
bringing my personal stream back to a
return but one day one day one day the
other thing too is I was streaming a lot
on my lap who is fog of war because it's
like too much Oh
pogo stick man is back oh he did a
little friend flip this time he's
learned a new ability whoo yeah make him
jump into the fire oh boy oh boy ding
come to me when someone can't snipe me
with fire bombs I think we still have no
idea where it came from
we're switching your stances can lead to
openings for attacks yeah might help
like the recovery of some other attacks
oh yeah I would shoot on my laptop and
you know everything was going perfectly
perfectly font no the fire nothing's
going perfectly and then all of a sudden
one day my computer was like you know
what do this anymore
just gonna lag all the time and so yeah
I guess that's uh yeah Dennis says
Barcade on 24 shed Chi Street and
Manhattan got street fighter the movie
arcade video game and sunset writers
arcade video game - I love Barcade I've
been in the one in Brooklyn and the one
that's on st. Mark's Street kind of next
to you like the karaoke singing places I
love st. Mark's like st. Mark's is great
they have awesome Japanese food like the
places where it's like it doesn't open
till like 6 o'clock and there's a line
outside like paper you gotta sign it and
hope you're early enough it really
really good places we are playing the
neo - closed alpha demo and yeah and
we're also poisoned poisoned he breathes
his bad breath on you I do have
antidotes like I have nothing for the
poison you know your character is like a
bass preset that you can pick from but
she's still looks super badass Adrian
asks how similar is this to Sakura how
similar it's hard it's a hard game
that's how it's similar to Sakura which
one do you like more of the two I feel
like it's an unfair comparison I I'm on
my third playthrough a sec you're gonna
play this for like 45 mmm I really like
Sakura like suck you're my but this game
is fine game is fine it's just bye
why Thank You hacker for a subscribe and
we appreciate that um yeah we stream
every weekday at 11 a.m.
sometimes we alter times to work around
the games that we're gonna play but 11
a.m. is a pretty safe time to tune in
yeah thanks finally for all of you
tuning in today it's Wednesday get that
oh my goodness Adrienne with the heavy
hitting questions what's your favorite
game of all time it's like choosing a
favorite child so chilled said he
wouldn't compare Sakura and mio because
the game of mechanics differ extremely
they're pretty different like I think
the only major similarity between them
is that you have to measure something
while you're fighting and suck your oh
it's your posture and in this one it's
your stamina but like other than that
like that's the loosest when do people
start heading out for III it's too soon
around here III is like Voldemort like
people know it's a big deal and they
don't want to mention it but there's
nothing you could do to avoid it at the
same time but I'm super excited for III
because it's my first time being at e3
kind of a part of like something bigger
than just going for myself you know
which I went like the last two years
it's been kind of open to the public in
a way so I'm pretty excited this year to
be a person awesome
you know just experiencing it in a
different way I actually leave the
Sunday before it started so I get there
a little bit you get there Sunday yes I
lose my leaves
yeah yeah is there one of the early ones
excited I'll be there Monday yay
it's so cool see because we're having
like the gamespot party too and I'm like
this is awesome
chessy was like yeah you know you'll be
working at the event and it's mandatory
you go to this party I'm like hey guys
tell me why is mandatory party you will
drink and you will have fun they will
like it you will enjoy it I'm super
looking forward to it um back to
favorite games of all time geez yeah
that's really tough but I don't want to
like ignore the question I think I did
mention this before but Yoshi's Island
is one of my favorite games halo 2 one
of my favorite games also um Ocarina of
Time is definitely up there and one of
my favorite games ever I just really
like that
in the music I stabbed the Lost Woods
song as my ringtone for a really really
long time I just got a new phone I
haven't changed anything custom but yeah
also like just like finding weird games
and playing them and oh my god yes he
didn't just slam you've a slam you into
the fire I was squeezed squeezed wrong
game um yeah oh she's Island awesome I
feel like Michael and Callie and a bunch
of other people would come in here and
angrily like glare at me if I didn't say
one of the mass effects wasn't my
favorite game consider I come to work in
an in seven hoodie every single day so
I'm gonna go with two two seems like a
safe choice yeah you know there's a
special love for a game when you start
buying merging here and stuff like that
I used to have this halo share where
it's like the front print was like a
front of Spartan armor in and on the
back it was the back of Spartan little
fire Jordans they'll fire damage damages
you so quickly I thought I would have
time to quickly just get in and hit him
once and then just jump ben says it's
shoe I was waiting for the mass effect
someone else asked a good question let
me go up they don't want to forget it
what are you most excited for it III
that's rough because I definitely feel
like I haven't seen all of the weeks are
upcoming things for e3 and also there's
gonna be something that I know it oh my
god II hate you with the 3-piece Jordan
I'm not doing well I'm doing worse
dodging we if you can dodge a pickaxe
weights backwards even dodge a wrench
you could dodge a pickaxe looking
forward to cyberpunk seeing what a CD
Projekt RED has
I'm kinda excited to see if there's
gonna be any surprises or like you know
people are speculating about something
for a long time or it was all rumors for
a long time like hint hint
I don't know Marvel for I don't know
that would be awesome but hey dreams
dreams can be dreams
Jordan care about your life curious to
see if the rumor that from software is
going to announce a new game that Jordan
Martin helped with during the Microsoft
press conference because they have three
unannounced games ah you you're the one
oh no he stops I hope it hit it hit one
shot that's all we needed
I said there's gonna be something at e3
elaborate what was I talking about oh
yeah you guys if you are going to be
anywhere near the e3 area during e3 come
check out the GameSpot track cuz you
don't need a pass to come to the game
spot you know it's outside and we're
gonna have games and we're gonna have
meet and greets and it's gonna be super
fun
and I right now I'm working on my first
cosplay ever to wear to e3 I don't know
if you guys have seen the new overwatch
skins but honeydew may is so cute so I'm
working on a cosplay of her right now I
just started it yesterday the aprons
almost done oh he's almost dead you have
plenty of like fire no no I don't I
don't have enough
it took like 300 damage is Las Vegas
fire in any video game ever so yeah if
you guys gonna be anywhere near an area
it's in LA crime said Jordan without I'm
sorry fire we need one of those like
heat-resistant blankets character let's
pray I think that's a good idea
let's pray pray on it yeah we did see
the dust stranding trailer I'm sorry I'm
gonna pronounce this wrong for air seven
four yeah sorry fairy is it fair it's
cuz the seven is at a tea the seventh of
tea fair it it yeah we did see it and
it's awesome I love it I'm probably
gonna watch it again after the stream is
over cuz it was just beautiful there's
definitely okay it is peridot ha ha
thank you for the confirmation
I had to whip out my my gamer language
right
it was like all three three seven when
did we start YouTube well a long time
ago I'm sure cuz I remember games but
like back when I was younger it's kind
of surreal to be here now to be honest
still it's been over a month almost too
since I'm in right here so yeah don't
let your dreams be dreams guys all right
no yes yeah die you die like how it does
like 15 damage to him but like you
hopped into it and they're like 300
damage unfortunately I don't have any
arrows this time it's okay just just
pull Pogo man from there you step over
here step into my office
take your office nice play the safe game
I like this new approach straight in
I like the patients here the neutral Oh
dodge those oh it's fine that's fine
it didn't hurt too bad oh it did six
damage to him yeah I was like 12
ooh let's get another 12 oh that was
like 25
[Laughter]
burn burn burn oh yeah that was the
question from earlier do we remember
like how old we were when we started
gaming or our first game and if so what
console okay I don't know if I can say I
remember the first game I ever played
but I did start getting like back when I
was kid I have an older brother and both
my parents also you know play game so
Crash Bandicoot was the first game I
beat with my mom and f-zero was the
first game that like I played with and
like kind of completed like with my dad
and then my brothers so I actually the
one who introduced me to Halo 2 like he
had bought an an xbox original Xbox off
of a friend and the discs like just so
happen to be in the console so that is
like started playing we were like okay
this works so it was pretty great but
you know growing up I remember playing a
lot of different things that I look at
now and I'm like oh yeah I remember to
use those elixirs like even if you're
half-life I would just use it anyways
cuz that did more than half your life
just in one throw let's see what else
yeah like we play me and my brother
actually play this old Madden game so
much and you know this was back when
there was like you have a memory card
and if he did so we left this football
game on on this big screen TV and this
was way back in the day so like a big
screen was literally a big screen it was
like huge box it was like three feet
wide and
you know huge those big old screens
right and we left the game wine like we
wouldn't like ate dinner or something
really came back and we were playing all
day then we switched it to a regular
cable and the the outline of the
football field was like burned into the
screen and you could see it like vaguely
overlaying all this the shows and was
love I like food foods not good same I
first console was a gameboy advance and
I cannot to this day remember if my
first game was Metroid Fusion or if it
was pokemon ruby I got into games very
late I didn't start playing them until I
was in 3rd or 4th grade very late by
gamers by gamers and poor most people
are like 4 or 5 and their older siblings
like get them into it but I was the
older sibling it was your duty sister
and I played an uncomfortable amount of
Lego Star Wars did you have any Spyro
games or Sly Cooper games I did play
spyro I loved spiral I thought he was
adorable and I actually really enjoyed
those games especially after playing a
lot of Crash Bandicoot I kind of got you
know Allies to see him vibes in that
style of game but I never tried the Sly
Cooper games and those was always like
pretty cool too oh he's chilling let him
bleed out yeah you stay right there let
him bleed out burn a slow game of the
patience let's see Oh something cool I
think actually is that you know growing
up and when I was younger I didn't
really understand that there were like
strict genres right like you
your image oh my god is so much damage
heal yourself now yeah healed right
before he hit me oh maybe we should go
demon mode oh yeah I'm scared to go more
though
okay demon mode over yeah so genres
right you know when I was younger I just
thought you know games all games games
then I get older I started competing I
start really okay yes yes I'm like
competing in FPS games then it was like
oh you want to be godlike competing in
fps well you better have a team you
better have other it lets you know three
other people ready to like dedicate
their time impossible so then I was like
hey I want to compete still but I don't
want to rely on a team I started playing
fighting games fighting games are hard
man yes I was just like struggling but
as I started learning more about
fighting games you know I started
playing Tekken a little bit and I had
never played a 3d fighting game I'd
always been a 2d fighting game player
but then I started playing and realizing
oh I did play this when I was younger a
zero idea what I was doing I mashed all
the buttons I was always the bear like
the bear is cute I think what I think
one of the tycoons there was a kangaroo
and I played him a lot it's here just
because they were adorable but I also
remember just like not understanding the
concept of the game at all sometimes
would be like why can't I get off the
floor
or if it was so low caliber my brother
would just push me to the edge and wring
out every time
like this is not fair I cannot compute
like what's going on but now that I am a
fighting game player and I do understand
fighting games I'm like oh this is
actually really cool now you're an
expert yeah yeah I know but they are to
you about pressing some buttons but yeah
so that's my story on remembering I've
played games that I play now in the past
but not realizing it was that game that
just happens sometimes
I also remember just playing like really
old weird but also like games that were
probably on clearance so like my parents
always got us like these games are
really like cheap and like good sales
and stuff which they might not have
always been the greatest games but some
of those were really good like I think
the first time I ever played pokey
Stadium was it was a clearance game and
my parents got it for me and then the
minigames in that game was probably one
of my favorite things of all time you
and what else what else oh yeah that
like track what I feel like this Pogo
guy is more dangerous in the first Pogo
guy we ran into earlier it's a little
bit more nimble I feel like I'm playing
too greedy that could be it all so now
that I've been playing second for a
while my my favorite Tekken character I
don't know I definitely have to go with
panda but negan if you guys didn't know
if your Walking Dead fan negan is in
Tekken 7 now and I was at Evo when they
announced it and I almost like
[Music]
mind blown I loved it thought it was
great people were in hating on the
choice well I'm actually a fan I like
read the the graphic novels or whatever
you want to call it and that was it was
pretty good too so I was excited about
that crash team racing the chat
reminding me is coming out I'm really
excited I've never been the greatest at
like kart racing you know but I love
them because they're really fun so I'm
really looking forward to that we were
playing the team sonic racing recently
which was really fun too because it's
like a team of three type things us and
you can like work with your teammates
and share items so I can only assume the
crash version oh my goodness they're
just hitting me with the combos right I
got my money I got my money
yeah let's go back and play
I need a prayer Jesus but yes I am
excited for Crash Team Racing because it
does have that like nostalgia feel to
really excited for it yeah I was like
wait the homies good I accidentally
attacked them they forgave me they came
back what else I was gonna say gonna say
so oh yeah so in terms of like racing
games right it's like Mario Kart that
game takes some skill all right I did
not currently have that ability but one
day I will but when I was playing Sonic
Team Racing the sonic kart racing game
that would fall a little a little
friendly so I think I will be ready once
Crash Team Racing comes out but back in
the day I actually really really loved
it was a DS game but the Cartoon Network
racing game
really really like that you know those
were the glory days when I had my DIA
flight and I had my are for work hard
and I was downloading all these games
from EMU paradise and I had like I had
like 40 games on that r4 and it was
fantastic that's when I first played all
the Ace Attorney games and I was like
Phoenix Wright is amazing and then he
like was in Marvel 3 and I was like okay
this is random but I loved it
you know touches D s you know I played a
lot of that on my Deus lay also Sonic
Riders the fire that was a slow burn
that was all right we have seven minutes
you can defeat Pogo and in seven minutes
I believe in you I could only do it when
I had an hour Diddy Kong Racing I say
have not tried them yeah I think like
the kart racing games I have tried was
sonic Mario Kart obviously I feel like
everyone that's like a rite of passage
do you at least gotta play Mario Kart
one time in your life there's enough of
them right now
I know yet invincibility during the
animation do a barrel roll what are the
notations for a barrel roll and I do
like traditional well they're all
traditional racing games but like me for
speed and for is a import tuner was also
a racing game I really like they had me
free speed man that is like a classic
racing everyone played that but real
talk the drag race was my absolute
favorite probably cuz it was a little
more simple like straight line but it
was all about how well you could shift
finding that time
MK 11 date patch for the PC version
question mark says Roger I'm not sure I
know that they just added the combo
breaker stage which was awesome and they
also added like a special Tower I think
that had Rick who runs combo breaker
they had like his shadow here but as far
as actual patch oh you got this oh you
got this no oh no just heal now just you
know nice we're full life we're healthy
we got this wait I tell you I put a time
limit on you beating him and now you're
destroying him keep it up keep we got
this talk it's all good got all day oh
nice black its final oh my gosh oh yeah
yeah slow play I like it burn burn to
death white won't you burn now no fire
right now okay you had like a pixel and
you like yeah barely stuff yeah
thankfully I remembered I was not at
home and I'm not allowed to throw this
controller not here you know I'll be at
home playing stuff and I'm like raging
out and then I come here and play and
I'm like happens all the time
hey that was definitely the closest run
we now have four minutes for you to beat
this bus I believe in you
shade Sam right raises in and I have me
first feet underground to you on ps4
yeah that would be awesome
but need for speed those games were
we're coming out during a prime time for
them to come out right this is when Fast
and the Furious was popping and everyone
wanted to be a street racer it was it
was good timing I remember some of the
newer Need for Speed though they were
like they have story mode like payback
outside of the car I'm like what's going
on ever being like this like you're in
that car you might have a few cutscenes
but you were still in the car during the
cutscene oh yeah we need in either early
heal oh my oh boy
okay okay this runs not going as smooth
by still babies it's not going well
oh yeah he could go in the ride it does
no damage them like Oh meet the hard day
yeah he's the greatest fighting game
player of all time his reads are OnPoint
[Laughter]
idea equals true true you know
Alessandro and Matt are actually
confident at this game but both of them
are busy so I had to step in hey I still
believe we have three minutes that's
plenty of time we got three more elixirs
we can't buy any items from our little
prayer circle well I'd have to go get my
money alright no time to obtain the
green we just got to go and fight Pogo
man
hacker said he's from Russia and he's
gonna come visit us in America well come
on through III isn't like eleven days or
something like that we have this screen
in the office that has a countdown of
winning in three years no you you did
this to me what am i hoping for at e3
Marvel for I'm hoping also for the Fifth
Element open-world game that doesn't
exist I'm just throwing things out there
that I wish would happen I'm also hoping
for a ghost hunting virtual reality game
like the anime or literally just regular
good like parent like ghost hunting like
go into a haunted house and you have all
your equipment and you got to try to
like search for ghosts obviously you're
gonna catch some crazy stuff I think
that would be a cool concept really good
VR horror game anime at first
hey ghost hunting enemy I'm done like I
like anime by know there's so many I
haven't seen that you know I should see
and I always tend to gravitate towards
the ones that are like based on
something I like like Kuroko's
basketball is probably one of my
favorite and I like basketball watches
so it's like a natural fit things like
that like food Wars I love food minute
left do you want to believe in you okay
this is our final attempt oh go man we
have to lick sirs what's that at the
bottom Saul and you throw some salt at
him make I tried and liked it did
nothing three damage in real life salt
she does more damage than that oh and
then he got a little fire guy behind you
oh his his hammer throws fire at you
also I notice right there and that last
hit I think yeah burned a little bit so
not only does it knock you back into
them also brings you the same well
hey we did good work today you sliced
and diced you stopped the little
cannibals we rescued two of our little
dudes oh I'll get I'll get better as
soon as I get out of my Secura Rhett get
back into how you actually play me Oh
which is kind of like Dark Souls
I'll play some Dark Souls 3 over the
next few months yeah and yeah guys this
is the neo to alpha demo so obviously
it's right up the alley of the first neo
but you should also keep in mind that
things in the final gameplay could be
different and they say that too when you
start the game but yeah we hope you
enjoyed the stream thanks for tuning in
and watching hope you're having a good
Wednesday we're halfway through the week
so almost there to the weekend we're
here every day Monday through Friday at
11 a.m. so be sure to tune in and thanks
everyone who subscribed today we have
people say that they subs we appreciate
it yeah so we will catch guys next time
tomorrow I believe we're gonna be
playing void bastards so should be super
fun looking forward to it to it and I
hope guys have a good day so peace out